たどっています
昨日のリハーサルはすごいうまくいったと自分で思ってるんですけど
今日いろんな先生とかの話とか聞いて
休み時間にサングラスかけてビートボックスやってる人とか見てえ
俺のプレゼンやばくねって思ったんですよねなのでちょっと今すごい緊張しているので
ちょっと
いろんなことを話しながらだんだん僕が話そうと思っている事について話していこうと
思います
まず僕という人間についてちょっとだけ話します別にスライドが黒いからっていう理由
で病んでるわけじゃないですか
なんか昨日見せた時病んでるじゃんと言うんですけど
多分やんじゃないと思います
今日最初に渡辺先生が言ってたみたいな感じで
ここにいる人は結構意識高い系の人が多いと
聞いているとそういうふうに思いました僕ん
残念ながら僕は違うと思っています僕の自分の事が
僕がどんな人間かというとこういう周りにいる
意識たが来て何かをやっていて恩恵何かを頑張っている人
っていうのが多いように見えるんですけど僕はどっちかというと周りがそういう人が
多くて
どうすればいいかっていうふうに焦っている側の人間だと思っています
でこんな僕が今日どんなことを伝えたいのかっていう話に移っていこうと思います
僕は小指球と今まであまり何かを本気であったことがありません
小さい頃からずっと何かやってるときに
あっていけないわと思ったときにだいたい口に出してできないっていう風に言うんです
よね
その時絶対に父に言われたことがあります
劣勢だユーキャンツーは旧制第いうキャラとは言えば be able to
どういうことかというと
日本語訳に直すと分かると思いますけどできないっていうと絶対に出来ないよと
マインドセットが大事だと
それに言われたんですよ
小さいからの試小さい公の僕からしたら書籍ていい兄が開かなかったんですよ
なんでかっていうと
だって俺できないって思ってるのもできないって思ってのになんでべきないっちゃダメ
なのみたいなそんな感じだったんですよ
代金になってようやくそのできないって言ったらなんでダメなのかっていう
そのリングっていうか大切さが分かってきたので
それのそれについてのマインドセットについてちょっと関連していることについて
今日は皆さんにお話ししたいと思います
僕のテーマは
区別すると何が起こるかっていうテーマです
超四球と皆さん何も想像できないと思います
僕も自分でもよくわかりません
みなさんこれを見て今どう思いましたか
僕のことじゃなくてあのこの画面に映っている写真の方についてです
多分ですけど皆さんが想像したのはあ
の米商
科学者転載
バイオリンが弾ける科学者
そう大勢4
南庭でしたっけあってるかな
みたいなことを想像したと思います
今皆さんは
アインシュタインという人をカテゴライズしました
アインシュタインは天才である
アインシュタインは科学者である
カテゴライズというのは区別をするということです物事を分離することをカテゴライズ
と言います
僕が小さいと企業チェーン生だった頃の写真を初めて見た時に思ったことは一つでした
変なおっさんだなぁと思いました
ただしているし髪の毛変だしどう考えてもバカだろこの人って思いました
その後中学校高校小学校いろんなところでいろんなことを学んでいくうちに
ここに写っている人があ
いろんなことを発見しているすごいしたっていうことを学びました
その後僕が思ったことはいい
もう一羽がなぁというイメージから尊敬しできる人だなっていうふうにイメージが
変わりました
どういうことかっていうとカテゴリーというものは
カテゴリーが自分にとって持つ意味っていうのは自分が持っている知識経験によって
変わってきます
大きくなってかについてそれが自分に対して持つイメージ
は変わってくる
こういうことがいいです
このカテゴライズということはとても
ようなことです
でも皆さんは今
アインシュタインを見て天才だっていうふうにパって出てきましたよね
無意識下でえっ
女に自分のモノに対して接する
接し方を変えてくるカテゴライズっていうものなんですが
米式のこれも行われます深く考えずにです
服の中でへ
一番接し方が変わったと思っていうことが一つあります
一番なんで一つしかないんですけど
勉強についてです
弁慶っていうよりも学びて行ったほうがいいかもしれません
小さい頃の僕が読書がすごい好きでした
映画もよく観ましたし
えっと映画もよく観ましたし
博物館にはよく行きました
そこで僕はいろんなことを学びました
が中の仕組みとか
地球がどういう風にできたかとか
これら全部9小学校の中学園よりも前に学んだことでした
恥ずかしながら僕が今持っている知識の70%ぐらいは
たぶんその頃までに得た知識だと思っています
なぜ
こんなに貪欲に知識を集めることが好きだった僕が知識を集めなかったのか
それについて今から少し話したいと思います
主に2つ要因がありました
一つ目
僕が反抗期だから
あー話はちょっと生じキュートこの話のこのテーマの代わりに話そうと思っていたこと
でもあるんですけど僕は教育のシステムが生じ切って
酒ていると思ってます
教育はシステムっていうか日本のその教育に対する
考え方みたいのがふざけてると思ってるんですけど例えば大学に行かなきゃいけないと
か
大学院行かないと良い就職先が見つからないとか
そのせいで別に大学に行かなくてもいいような人が大学に行かなきゃいけないですよ
大学行って何やってるかというと遊んでるんですよ
そしたら大学ていく皆言って僕は思うんですよねすごいいっぱい敵作っちゃったと思う
んですけどできればそういう形を流していただけるといいなと思っています
まあ反抗期ですからこういうことをよく考えるんですよねうか
まあこっちは堂山来てへ
もう一つの炎要因があるんですよ
花冷えのイメージが変わったから
さっき言った通り昔の僕にとっての勉強っていうのは
学びっていうのは
自由だったんですそこらへんにある好きな本好きな種類の本を上によってきて
それをパラパラ4
それで僕は知識を集めていました
博物館に行って歩いていろんなそこらへんにあるパネルとか読んで
多そうなんだっつってそれで学んでました
自由で楽しかったんですよ
それが変わったのが
中学受験の最後の方
憲法の前文を覚えろって言われたんですよ
正直で意味わかりませんでした覚えたところ何もなんないし一つ一つの意味を
言葉を覚える必要はないわけですよだいたいざっくりということが言いたいのかっての
小屋を覚えればいいのに
テストとかで聞かれるのは
この部分はどういう単語が入ってましたかみたいな
その時初めて僕は学びっていうものを窮屈だなって思いました
その時初めてテストで点を取るために勉強しました
それから僕にとって勉強っていうそこで初めて僕にとって勉強っていうカテゴリーが
できたんですよね
それまで学びっていう自由で楽しいカテゴリーだった勉強勉強
花火があっ
勉強というカテゴリー news って窮屈
つまらないものを持ったんですよね
それから僕は勉強するの
受け身的に勉強するようになりました
学校で出された宿題をやって
家で親に言われるから勉強して
みたいな
ことやってたんですよね
今さっきいそずみ先生が話してたような
ことでいうと2四球とやっちゃいけないことだと思いますし自分の今の中でも
時間の無駄になっているなというふうに感じた維持します
どうしてこのように変わったかというと向かいます
勉強っていうものが自由で楽しいものから窮屈でつまらないものった強制されるものに
なった
これがいうです
今考えるとすごいバカバカしいんですよ
どう考えてもおかしいですよこの
飼い方はなぜかっていうと学校で強制されている勉強以外にも自分で勝手にやれる勉強
というものはあるし
学校の勉強の中にも自分が好きな教科はある
なのに小学生だったところの僕とか中学生の頃の僕と彼はあ
すべての勉強に同じことはでハメちゃったって
ベストでやるからテストの為に勉強することになる
だからつまらない
今しっかり考えてみると
その議論というのはすごいおかしくて
別にそういう風に考える必要はなかっ
なぜこんな勘違いが起こったのかというと最初に言いましたが
カテゴライズしたからですカテゴライズっていうのは
無意識下で行われます
だから深く考えません
その時の感情に押し流されます
もう一回落ち着いて考えると実はその理論が間違ってたりします
皆さんに今日覚えておいて欲しいことは一つ目
もう一度自分がものに対して
持っている感情持っているイメージカテゴライズ
をしているものに対してもっていうイメージが本当に自分にとって正しいのか
それがもし自分に対してネガティブな影響を与えて言うならば
ポジティブにはどういう風に働くのかということを考えてほしいです
今話したのはあ
自分がものをカテゴライズした場合です
もう一つ
カテゴライズには種類があります
いま流行している流行している流行っている
練習差別
よくテレビで聞きますけどこれがその例です
栄がすでにカテゴライズをしている場合
こっちの場合は
そもそも変えるのが難しい社会的にも常識になっているので
このおっ
g サービスがどういうふうに言われるかっていうと僕の想像だと
どっかの誰かさんが勝手に
この人たち自分と違いは
だから
区別しようみたいな感じで誰か来始めた
それが社会の常識になっているみたいな感じだと思います
さっき言ったとおりこれは変えるのは難しいです
トランプがトランペ前大統領が
アラビア圏の人には
アメリカに入らせないみたいなことをやったと思いましたしか
理由としてはテロリストが多いから
そのせいで人々には
イラクとかに住んでいる人はテロリストである
というイメージがきました
実際はそうではないの良いです
人はそのカテゴリーについているイメージ
があるとそのイメージに考え方を制限されます
だからもしそういうふうに社会的にカテゴライズしているっていうことに気づいたなぁ
本当にそれがもう人々の真の姿なのか
その物事の真の姿なのかっていうのを確認するべきだと思います
具体的にどうすればいいかは僕もよくわかりませんでも一つ言えるのは
例えば人種差別だったらその人に実際に会って話してみる
いって本当に体験してみるというのが一番良い方法だと思います
カテゴライズには2つの種類がありますひとつ目
何がカテゴライズしている場合
二つ目
社会がカテゴライズしている場合
カテゴライズとは自分の
行動を制限するものです
ネガティブにもポジティブに
ネガティブな場合はできないなどのネガティブな感情を
そのカテゴリーに植え付けている
だから自分はそれができるというふうに思
だから挑戦しなくなる
逆に者ポジティブに働くのはどういうときか
これは
できるって思ったり
得意やる
ように思う時ですそれにそのカテゴリーをカテゴライズしていればいいです
そういうときには自分にとってポジティブに働くことが多い
最後に
言葉をおととい見つけたので皆さんに超
よってスペクティブイーベイ神 op ヴェゼル応用パスポーちー
ということか若いわかると思います
あなたたちの考え方視点っていうのは
あなたを縛るものです
それは自分をその場所に縛り付ける
牢獄になるかもしれないし逆にあなたを次のステップに持っていくパスポートになるか
もしれません
こういう言葉です
別にカテゴライズをすることが悪いっていうふうに言っているわけでありませんただ
そのカテゴライズをしているときにそのカテゴリーについてくるイメージ
それが自分にとって本当にポジティブなイメージなのか
それがネガティブなイメージならばそれをどうやってポジティブに変えていくことが
できるのか
皆さんに
てほしいなと思います
色々と出来ていないことがあるので
をしっかり
考えながら
よっていこうと思っていますがとうございました